ladies and gentlemen welcome to the 10
million dollar studio let me say up top
this investigation will contain
potential money laundering unregulated
offshore gambling and worst of all
influencers this is a million dollar
video i just realized i spent 600 000 on
watches i lost two hundred thousand
dollars to six nine sixty thousand in
private planes twenty thousand on hotels
in mexico a hundred thousand rolex in
cars yeah it feels good to be a winner
this is the first in a six-part series
in collaboration with some ordinary
gamers exposing the secret world of
unregulated offshore crypto gambling and
how influencers have become filthy rich
by being the gasoline on the fire
promoting it around the world and making
it into the billion dollar phenomenon it
is globally now i'll be honest when i
first started looking at this i had no
idea about any of that the reason i'm
actually here starts off the way all
great stories start with twitter beef
alright here's how this went down i had
been hearing for a while about how
online unregulated crypto casinos were
hiring some of the biggest influencers
in the world to promote them and then
would pay them for every fan they got to
sign up and not only that every time
their fans would lose money to the
casino the influencer would make a cut
on those losses now i thought this was
insane and i said enough's enough it's
time to act so i tweeted about it quote
just found out that the top gambling
streamers are getting paid a percentage
of their signups losses so not only are
streamers getting paid to promote
gambling to their fans they're literally
incentivized for their fans to lose as
much as possible how do these people
sleep at night now normally i expect my
tweets to go into the great void of
jack's armpit but this time i guess one
of those gambling streamers actually saw
it and he responded
steve will do it now i can't imagine why
he felt singled out by my tweet but he
was pissed off that i would accuse him
of profiting off the losses of his fans
he told me hey you broke [ __ ] do your
research rubette's affiliate program has
nothing to do with losing it's about the
bet rhubat is different than other
gambling websites do your research you
broke [ __ ] before you post like this
publicly given his thoughtful response i
thought hey maybe i made a mistake so i
went back and checked rubet's affiliate
terms and it turns out he's right grubet
doesn't give influencers a percentage of
their fans losses rubeck gives their
influencers a percentage of the
mathematical odds of their fans losing
this is straight from rubet's page
affiliates receive a commission of five
percent of the mathematical house edge
on all their referrals wagers with that
percentage increasing as the referrer
climbs the tiers and if you're thinking
right now wow that sounds like basically
exactly the same thing it is the exact
same thing just with a little ethical
distancing it's kind of clever actually
because now instead of being directly
tied to their fans losses they complete
innocent they're still profiting from
their fans but you know in that indirect
economic percentage sort of way it's
kind of like saying no i didn't bomb
those syrian kids i just sent the drone
the dead it's the exact same thing it
just sounds a little bit better but
anyways we fired back and forth a few
times he eventually deleted his
responses but something he said always
stuck with me and no it wasn't the part
about him sleeping very well at night
living in a penthouse knowing that i
change people's lives every day and i'm
rich it wasn't even hey you broke loser
it was actually
this do your research
which is why this series now exists and
steve will do it legally can't be mad
about it because technically he's the
one who asked for this so um
yeah steve
this one's for you now i want to be
clear ladies and gentlemen a small sense
of vindictiveness is not why i'm telling
you this story today it is a small
reason okay i'll admit that but it would
have never carried me through this
investigation which had so many dead
ends what actually hooked me and kept me
going on this investigation was a single
question
how
is this video
possible it shouldn't exist now explain
what i mean let's go to the board
because i gotta explain a little more
about steve will do it for a little
context
steve is a member of nelk an insanely
popular youtube channel known for their
pranks like trying to use monopoly money
at a casino kind of weird foreshadowing
to be honest but they generally make fun
popular videos with a lot of money being
thrown around cars being gifted partying
that kind of thing but the money i was
seeing thrown around specifically in
stephen dewitt's videos was too much it
didn't make any sense like every video
it was private jets buying exotic cars
giving away hundreds of thousands of
dollars and going off my experience with
youtube i knew something was off see
remember that video i mentioned the
million dollar one it only had 4.3
million views and in that video he
really does spend a million dollars this
is a million dollar video i just
realized by contrast the only other
youtuber in the world i know of that can
afford that kind of spending is mr beast
who regularly gets 50 plus million views
on a video and there's always a sponsor
on those videos to recoup some of that
cost but here's the weird thing on
steve's video with 10 times fewer views
there's no sponsor and that's how so
many of his videos are he's throwing
around money like mr beast but he has a
fraction of the views and he's not
sponsored so it begs the question where
is this massive cash flow coming from is
steve will do it the son of assadi
prince like this dude seems to have
endless amounts of cash oil barren
amounts of cash and at first i thought
okay wait a second happy dad their new
alcohol company right but it can't be
that because this spending predates that
well maybe it's merch then
that's the nelk boys thing right they
pull in 70 million dollars a year
selling their merch maybe selling hats
is how steve affords to live like the
son of a president and i would have
thought that but right as i was about to
give up someone gave me a helping hand
on a drunken live stream let's let's
bring down the board here i've
figured out
other ways to make money
so
i don't i'm not
big because i feel like a baller right
now i don't take private planes i don't
buy three hundred thousand dollar
watches i don't
buy
whatever but today i just bought a
two hundred thousand dollar sprayer
badass i can't i don't do that i'm
selling t-shirts dude it's actually
impossible
i've figured out like
i've gotten financial advice
this and that from my two buddies
they've helped me out
so it's like they own wizards so it's
like
they've helped me make so much money to
wear
to where
i don't even want anything
wow when i saw this i thought to myself
is this guy confessing he talks about
getting financial advice from someone
that changed his life like from who
who who is it steve help us is it warren
buffett did you get advice from max
kaiser i mean honestly from the way he's
talking whatever this magical financial
advice is it dwarfs nelk's merch
business i can't i don't do that you're
selling t-shirts
it's actually impossible so what is this
financial secret what is this
knowledge immediately i started hunting
around at first i couldn't find much
just more evidence that steve will do it
of all people is more loaded than
possibly any other youtuber in the world
right now just watch this answer to a
question about finances from stevo's
podcast what is your mission
to be a billionaire gonna be a
billionaire all right to be a
billionaire yeah do you have a timeline
for that
three to five years three to five years
damn
what wait a second three to five years
he's not even saying that ironically or
is it drug he's like yeah what three to
five years i don't know i mean whatever
secret way he's talking about making
money earlier the kind of wealth that's
impossible selling merch that must be
what we're missing here the missing link
and i wasn't making much progress
finding out how he was doing it i
realized i had to focus up i gotta set
my ego aside i gotta make a change
[Music]
there we go i'm finally ready what
happened next was kind of hard to
stomach i spent the next several days
watching enough steve will do it content
to make my eyes bleed but finally all my
work paid off i finally found the
episode where steve once again mentions
his friend who made him so much money
alfonso has helped me a lot you know
with some financial [ __ ] like making
good financial moves money moves i'm
forever grateful for him and i'm gonna
gift him a richard mill okay so you need
he has a bunch of richard mills this
one's like a it's like a unique one okay
so we actually learned something here
one this
alfonso guy steve's special friend who
helped him he must be loaded right
because if he has a collection of
richard mill watches that regularly cost
hundreds of thousands of dollars
individually a collection would mean
he's at least worth several million
dollars minimum now at this point i'm
imagining several different possible
candidates for this mentor of steve's
obviously tai lopez being the first one
but i was completely wrong the financial
wizard behind the curtain is shockingly
young
so this is alfonso
yeah wait
this guy he looks like your average frat
bro in his mid-20s but even as that was
like breaking my brain things started to
make even less sense pay attention to
what he calls alfonso just a bit later
in this clip i'm gonna let it play for a
bit and this is doom 100 of the time 365
days of the year he wears a full send
slash steve will do it slash happy dad
shirt and allen knight whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa did you catch
that he calls him ellen
and he does it again later too
alan again huh why would steve will do
it miss label his friend to find out i
called up a friend of mine who's been
digging into this the third eye himself
because we need to get to the bottom of
who this mystery man is
phillian thanks so much for taking the
time i know you've been looking into
this who is this alfonso guy or alan
whoever it is all right so i tracked it
all down his name is alan he's a 25 year
old multi-millionaire running the los
angeles social media scene he owns both
rubette and wizza you know roubaid right
yeah it's that online casino that steve
will do it and all those guys are
gambling on right exactly except it's
offshore unregulated cryptocurrency
based and it's not legal in the us and
they are raking in tens of millions of
dollars per month oh my gosh wait a
second you're saying alan owns that
along with whizza as well yup those are
some big accusations how do you know
it's this like frat bro behind it all he
doesn't have his name on it right well
he does have rubet's name on himself
he's quite literally got a tattoo of it
on his wrist which he showcases above
his richard mill you know the 500 000
watches you know all the one that all
the 25 year olds own yeah yeah i mean i
got two of them but uh i got them also
on the transitive property of aiden ross
wait you got what do you mean you got a
clip for that or something of course
let's roll it this house is sponsored by
uh a company called like wizards i'm
sure i haven't paid rent at all but i
could do and if you guys can you guys
could literally help me come up with
giveaways like challenges and like like
last person to blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah like i can literally
promote how i want to do it how we want
to do it you guys can help me decide
like yo ayden you should do a giveaway
where you're doing this they're actually
really cool dudes bro and they're just
like me like they own rubet they own
that site right
not only that rubet's rocket fund llc is
also registered to the exact same
address as the wiza sweepstakes llc
which is 930 washington avenue suite 205
miami
33139 holy sh
it is the same guys
so when steve will do it's talking about
his friend who owns wiza helping him out
financially in in life he's talking
about reubet yup he's talking about
allen and not only that this guy allen
used to be part of the cs go gambling
scene back in the day under the name
arrow 1738 until he shut down his
youtube channel with 40 000 subscribers
and now since then he's tried to stay in
the dark it's the same scam all over
again exactly all right i know that's
been a lot so we're going to recap real
quick so steve will do it is like
insanely loaded because of this guy
whose name is alfonso but not alfonso
because that's actually an alias his
name is alan and he owns a sketchy
giveaway company called whizza but also
rubet which is an online gambling casino
which obviously gives us some context to
why steve will do it as defending
roubette so hard on twitter this is his
golden goose this is where his money is
coming from in fact remember that one
million dollar video i think we finally
have the answer to that it may not have
been sponsored but watching it again
there definitely was a sponsor in that
video this is definitely our guy he's
the reason for this lavish spending but
i also realized that this story might be
bigger than just steve yes he's loaded
and i'm determined to find out how much
money he's making from getting his fans
to gamble at offshore unregulated
casinos but there are many other
influencers also promoting rubet you've
got nelk aiden ross logan paul's friend
banks and you also got whizza how does
that play into this this sketchy
giveaway company and what about alfonso
there's just so much here i think i got
to make a call honestly
all right mood i'm passing this off to
you we need to do more research about
rubet how does it work how do you get
paid what's going on with all these la
influencers oh brother i'm already on it
look at the sky look at the stuff i
already found wait what what the hell is
this
kangaroo while he's heist why do you
want me to do that howie you're [ __ ]
weird as [ __ ] bro
[Music]
things will be different if i was
balling